So here's the answers. That a dynamic language will require less code. And there
are two reasons for that. One is because you don't need all the type
declarations. The other is code can be more versatile, in our python code we can
write a double procedure that works on both numbers and strings. Probably a bad
idea, but we can do it. With a statically typed language like Java, there's no
way to do that. You've got to write different procedures if you want them to
work on different types. A static language would be less likely for programs to
crash and the reason for that is because you find your bugs earlier. You find
them when you compile the program before their program is running, at least some
of the bugs. The more fun is a fairly subjective question. I'm going to go with
dynamic as more fun and it's more fun 'cause usually get things to happen more
quickly. It requires less effort to get a program working and behaving, pretty
close to correct. If it's a static language you have to get you program a lot
closer to correct before you can start playing with it. It's also easier to make
changes in a dynamic language. Other people might disagree and one problem with
that dynamic language, when all is going well, you can be nice and happy, if
things start to break with a dynamic language, you might have a much harder time
figuring out what's wrong than you would with a static language. But I'll stick
with my dynamic answer and I hope you enjoy Paranian Python. Which is a
dynamically typed language. Programs should execute faster, if they're written
as statically typed language. This depends a lot on the language. And the tools
that are used to do this and there's been a lot of improvements in making
dynamically typed languages run fast. But the execution tools have an advantage
in a statically typed language. There's less that they have to determine at run
time, and there's more they can do in advance. So they should still always be
able to run fast. Finally, which one is better for programming avionics? Well,
you really don't want to discover your type errors when you're at 30,000 feet,
much better to discover them before you take off. So there, static languages
have a big advantage.